philippe vigier on l'a entendu très peu
de remise en cause de la part du
gouvernement qu est-ce qui l'empêchent
finalement de reconnaître ses erreurs il
faut que notre ses horreurs
comme vous savez je suis partie de la
commission denquête à l'assemblée
nationale sur la gestion des masses est
une catastrophe
il ya eu des erreurs vous le dit
aujourd'hui sur les masques je suis dit
mais quand mu ce soit le mot et de vie
devant nous j'ai posé des questions très
simples des erreurs en appartement celle
de ceux qui ont fait faire du gel
hydroalcoolique on se débrouiller pour
faire les fabriques de masse on s'est
débrouillé pour aller aider le personnel
soignant
il ya un vrai sujet mais c'est pas
nouveau mais proposons pas de
circonstance que vous savez j'ai eu
l'honneur de conduire des travaux sur
une commission d enquête parlementaire
d'accès aux soins les ars sont hautement
déconnecté décalé du terrain voilà nous
on a beaucoup mangé le mois de mars au
mensonge 2e rue ou sur le coup j'ai
écouté lorsqu'on aura tous les éléments
on pourra 1 a déjà pas mal fait et vga
mais moi je lis songe qu elle apprendra
sur les matches qui ne l'ont pas dit
toute la vérité bien sûr nous ont pas
dit toute la vérité absolument quand
vous entendez florence parly qui admet
avoir menti sur france 2 en disant
qu'elle avait testé les militaires
finalement non c'est pas bien pour dire
la vérité il faut démissionner dans ces
cas-là du cac c'est pour moi qu'une
forme de gouvernement pas pourquoi elle
est allée dire des choses qui n'étaient
pas justes je pense qu'il faut dire
quelles sont ses faiblesses et ses
fauves c'est dans cette maladie qui est
une maladie terrible explosion
moi j'ai perdu mon frère lui colle un
médecin donc imaginer que ça m'a plus
impacté directement
donc on apprend aussi tous les jours je
vais vous dire franchement que sur les
par exemple sur les tests nous le
faisons à châteaudun laboratoire que
laquelle je travaillais encore un peu
parce que c'est également encore engagé
dans la vie publique dans la vie
professionnelle
eh bien on a priorisé parce que tester
tout le monde on peut pas le faire on
n'est pas en capacité de le faire après
les files d'attenté qui es-tu de
l'anxiété tout ce qui peut arriver
oui que les gens qui sont symptomatiques
il faut les tester que le personnel
soignant et ça c'est la stratégie du
gouvernement
testez travail ont évolué depuis
quelques jours cette stratégie des tests
ou pas aujourd'hui on peut pas sur tf1
simplement pour tester focaux derrière
faut des machines et des réactifs et on
n'a pas tout ce qu'il faut pour traiter
justement si vous avez de la chine est
suffisamment réactif sinon vous avez des
délais qui s'allongent
si vous avez des contraintes vous prenez
l'avion
vous n'avez pas un certificat comme quoi
vous êtes kobe négative 48 heures avant
c'est une sorte de vie de pouvoir passer
en plus pardonnez moi mais il ya 70% des
taux ce qui marche et à 30% ou
illégalité on peut pas tester tout le
monde c'est quoi la stratégie c'est
l'unité collectif qu'il faut qu'il faut
faire mais si on peut pas tester on peut
pas tester tout le monde à l'heure
actuelle car nous n'avons pas les moyens
matériels de ce nom en plus ça ne
servirait à rien vous testez les gens
symptomatique
il faut tester le personnel soignant et
faute et c'est tout ce qu'on était en
contact avec des patients et éviter
surtout l'explosion à laquelle on arrive
tout dire très franchement les choses
l'économie doit continuer on peut par
confiner la france ne peut pas se
permettre le luxe dans le confinement ce
n'est pas possible
en revanche principe de précaution
principe de précaution c'est que les
rassemblements où il ya trop de monde
les gens n'ont plus des gestes et varié
a coûté on sortait de l'hémicycle donc
de l'assemblée cette semaine à 00h30 y
avait encore au moins deux ou trois
mille personnes qui étaient sur le champ
de mars
agglutinés les uns avec les autres il ya
un vrai risque aliot avery et c'est là
où il faut faire attention parce que si
on ne le fait pas il vient il risque d'y
avoir à ce moment là une pandémie qui
sur le développent et moi je ne voudrais
pas que on en soit comme ça s'est passé
au printemps dernier à refuser des gens
en réanimation parce qu'on n'avait pas
suffisamment de lits disponibles
je n'oublie pas non plus que dans la
morbidité il ya des gens qui étaient des
maladies chroniques qu'on n'a pas pu
soigner qu'on a déprogrammé et donc
c'est pour ça selon vous on n'est pas
prêts là pour la sicile une des
nouvelles vagues qu'on n'est pas prêt je
n'ai pas dit ça il dit ça non justin
kurzel prêt dès le moment où on priorise
via des tests et en fait c'est quand
vous êtes malades qu on vous soigne
c'est pas quand vous n'êtes pas malade
quand vous pouvez avoir le coc vide est
asymptomatique ça veut dire quoi
symptomatique n'est pas de symptômes et
on n'est pas complètement certain que
quelqu'un d'assez automatique peut
transmettre obligatoire marième l'asie
d'anciens encore des incertitudes comme
sur le biologiste exprime encore la
direction générale de la santé je n'ai
pas fait de cadeaux tout le printemps
alors justement j'ai dit qu'il fallait
par exemple sur les anticorps avoir une
réponse
écoutez bien dans toutes les maladies
infectieuses tout produit des anticorps
protecteurs sauf une la syphilis quand
vous avez une rubéole vous ne refaites
pas nourri viol car vous faites une
toxoplasmose une femme quelle chance
d'avoir des enfants
on vérifie souvenons les immunisés
contre la rubéole toxoplasmose viger
j'aimerais parler aux politiques
je vais parler aux politiques agnès
buzyn était en audition
elle semble renvoyer la balle sur
l'administration le problème simplement
vouloir réformer cette admission pas
simplement j'ai auditionné le direction
générale de la santé de santé publique
france oui il faut réorganiser cette
administration la technostructure a
montré ses limites au bout d'un moment
ça ne marche alors comment ai je crée tu
mens qu'est ce qu'on fait bah coûteux
alors la partie au ministre résident
comment on fait d'abord j'avais arf
j'avais bien tomber si j'allais proposé
que les prix soient un seul patron de
l'ensemble des services dans un
département
la rs reviennent comme c'était
auparavant sous la tutelle des préfets
premier sujet comme seront un des
cirques l'action de l'état elle sera
liquidée de façon identique
deuxièmement et à cette forme
d'administration complètement décalé
voyez le politique s'exprime quand je
parle de l'accès aux soins
si la direction générale de l'offre de
soins n'étaient pas aussi réticente ces
populations nous avons fait quasiment
l'unanimité à l'assemblée et au sénat
dans cette maison on n'en serait pas là
pour la situation sanitaire donc que les
technocrates descendre sur le terrain
qu'ils aillent voir les patients et ça
ira nettement mieux